[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance after the worst ten days of
self-inflicted wounds in the history of
the American presidency it is clear that
this administration predicated on
revenge porn will end up in only one way
unless Trump resigns first he will be
impeached by a huge margin and he will
be convicted possibly unanimously not
necessarily because of Russia not
necessarily because of obstruction of
justice not necessarily because of
mental unfitness most likely because
Trump keeps threatening the people who
are politically on his own side I have
previously suggested here that this is
not so much a presidency as it is a
hostage situation it is now becoming
obvious that there's an added dimension
to that analogy it is a hostage
situation in which Donald Trump keeps
threatening to harm the hostages except
he doesn't have any hostages which still
hasn't stopped him from making a series
of increasingly ridiculous threats
against not hostages but against his own
party the Republicans who are literally
the only people standing between Trump
and his removal from office immediately
Saturday Trump threatened Congress all
of its representatives senators their
staffs Democrats Republicans threatened
to cut off their obamacare in case they
missed the point Monday morning he
threatened them more explicitly and
added a threat to the powerful insurance
Lobby which has spent millions to get
Republicans to oppose Obamacare for the
last decade if Obamacare is hurting
people and it is why shouldn't it hurt
the insurance companies and why should
Congress not be paying what public pays
he personally threatened twice about
money but congressmen who will
eventually vote on whether to impeach
him and he threatened the senators will
eventually vote on whether to convict
him and he threatened the industry that
makes huge donations mostly to
Republicans and he threatened the
Republicans the only group keeping him
for being removed from the White House
because he is still just barely popular
enough with his base to possibly be an
asset to the Republicans in the midterm
elections next
if you think I'm being pie-in-the-sky
about the Republicans eventually
impeaching the national embarrassment in
chief considered their response to the
story which he has endlessly called a
hoax and a witch-hunt and about which
Trump threatened everybody a bill to
sanction Russia for its interference in
our election last year which passed the
House and the Senate
by a combined 517 to five five five guys
on Trump's side of this more or less
Congress Herman Amash of Michigan Duncan
of Tennessee and Massie of Kentucky and
Senators Paul of Kentucky and Sanders of
Vermont and call me naive but I don't
think Trump can count on Bernie Sanders
voting to acquit him during the
impeachment trial incredibly after the
Russian sanctions vote Trump went right
back to threatening his own party John
McCain's famous thumbs down to kill the
last repeal Fiasco might as well have
been a different digit pointed in the
opposite direction it followed two years
of Trump abusing McCain and months of
him threatening every Republican senator
once remarkably enough to their faces
even the ones whose terms do not end
until after his will McCain didn't kill
repeal by himself of course Alaska
senator Lisa Murkowski was just as
valuable and her vote came two days
after Trump's hapless Secretary of the
Interior called up and threatened both
of Alaska's Republican senators with
what would amount to financial
punishments against their state because
Murkowski had voted no on a preliminary
health care vote the health care threats
against Republican senators and
congressmen and I keep emphasizing
Republican because Trump's behavior
makes you wonder if he frequently
forgets that he is a Republican these
threats did not end when the latest bill
to repeal Obamacare ended Saturday Trump
declared the Senate a joke because of
the 60-vote threshold that didn't apply
to this Obamacare vote anyway then he
specifically wrote that the Senate
Republicans quote look like fools
then he tweeted they are laughing at
Republicans and then
back at it in the afternoon tweeting
unless the Republican senators are total
quitters
the next day Trump's budget director
said it was official White House policy
that nothing else gets a vote in
Congress before healthcare again in
Congress were Trump lost on Russian
sanctions a total of 517 to 5 Congress
which clearly is no longer afraid of the
White House no longer counting to the
White House no longer paying attention
to the White House Congress which with
trumps approval even in the conservative
Rasmussen poll down to 39% does not have
to pay attention to him anymore but the
threats that may be putting the plan of
impeachment into the hearts of
Republicans and not just Democrats have
hardly been limited to Capitol Hill
Trump has threatened his own attorney
general he's threatened his former FBI
director he's threatened the special
counsel investigating his possible
complicity in the Russia scandal he's
threatened his former acting Attorney
General he's threatened his act press
Secretary's threatened his ex chief of
staff he's threatened China Germany
Australia Iran Canada Mexico Japan
jokingly or not he's also threatened his
ambassador to the United Nations his
director of Health and Human Services
his advisers Steve go Bannen yourself
Bannon and after he supposedly turned
over his business interests to his sons
he ended a presidential news conference
by threatening to fire his sons threats
are all Donald Trump knows they and
lawsuits and not paying his bills and
then daring you to sue him or how he
turned an inherited fortune into a
slightly larger fortune in only 40 years
they have worked because the world Trump
more or less succeeded in and the
character he played on television
consisted exclusively of other people
who could be bought or sold with money
or the promise of money or the threat of
less money and though money is far too
close to being the root of everything in
this country Trump has mistaken all of
politics all of governance all of
America for one large cash transaction
when in fact we are still based mostly
on clans
and demographic groups in ideology
everyday it must absolutely astound
Trump that hitting people with his
wallet just doesn't work in this
environment
his frustration is obvious it is
clouding what little judgment he had to
begin with it is hastening his removal
from office and that is the only service
he has ever done for his country 517 to
five resist remove peace